with bustling Brixton town centre on the
doorstep today we're trying a lunch
delivery service to see the public have
the appetite for prison made sandwiches
come on guys let's go we have to be
better than the competition
yeah this is not just a ploughman's and
a [ __ ] soggy sandwich if we're gonna
make a rap let me tell you it's gonna be
the best [ __ ] rap let's get prepped
if the lunches sell well my plan is to
start producing them five days a week
staff come together like that on the
menu
handmade wraps and sandwiches with the
choice of freshly prepared speciality
fillings yeah moist delicious roasted
red pepper hummus
hey roller in the seasoning try and keep
it on either side and a free-range
british favorite now that's a scotch egg
it's our Christmas Jubilee of the night
only a bread ex-coach eggs cold war my
dishes simple cheap and cheerful Scotch
egg let's get guys please
getting 250 lunches out before 11 a.m.
requires efficient teamwork my concern
is not all of this lot are up to it
11 order wetting is a global thing
I mean there have to learn to change
gear like an any job I mean talk about
changing gear look at norm
he's been stuck in [ __ ] eautiful 25
years convicted thief has an or is only
23
but he's already doing his third prison
stretch like it
uncle twins debris flap other traitors
over to endure a minute are you going
else oh yeah yeah however when you had
them okay now 14 yeah that's [ __ ]
young 14 yo where are the kids now when
was that from London but he got adopted
I can a single three kids
five kids we never heard of a condo 23
I've got five kids straightaway [ __ ]
you get labeled straightaway in it so
I'm really happy that my mom my dad my
sister
they think I'm a decade I kind of
respect how people forget as all but you
know just kind of leave the foster
player for wanted that car and money is
the issue if it means me still enjoy
them I can buy it then I have to make
sure don't get arrested
that's I used to think from there guys
15 minutes I'm out of here okay I'm not
afraid of a challenge but I've got my
hands full with her san kind of a
perfectionist deserve your kind of
perfections good idea puppy they look
like you know how I get me now hopefully
I don't get you that's just there yeah
so they don't want you out